the original lego star wars is the
granddaddy of the lego video game empire
a cute and hilarious take on the prequel
trilogy whose success spawned dozens of
licensed lego games now we're returning
to a galaxy far far away with lego star
wars the skywalker saga a massive
collection that takes you through all 9
core star wars movies including the two
final films in the sequel trilogy which
haven't been legofied yet but even
though we are returning to films already
covered before
don't expect a simple retread of the
previous games the skywalker saga is
built from the ground up and makes
changes to the traditional lego formula
to stand out
this is everything you need to know
about lego star wars the skywalker saga
as with all lego games the skywalker
saga is a retelling of the films but
keeps plot events simple and the tone
decidedly less serious
you'll visit every planet and major
location in the saga all redone in the
blocky style of lego from mos eisley
spaceport on tatooine the gunkin city
beneath the waters of naboo and the
ancient jedi ruins of akto the stories
all play out the same as their film
counterparts but with jokes thrown in to
keep you laughing you can't win but
there are alternatives to fighting
[Music]
the lego games have always delivered
solid gags and wholesome slapstick humor
gamespot editor jordan remay got the
chance to preview the game and found the
humor to be just as delightful as ever
saying i think this is ultimately going
to be an excellent way to enjoy star
wars regardless of whether you're a long
time fan or a new face in the galaxy far
far away continuing the trend of more
recent lego games skywalker saga has
original voice acting to recreate iconic
lines from the films as well as new
dialogue featured is a wide range of
returning talent from the live action
films like billy d williams's lando as
well as pulling from the star wars
animated series like james arnold taylor
for obi-wan skywalker saga is also the
final acting credit for the legendary
tom kane who retired in november 2021
after suffering from a stroke if you're
wondering if your favorite star wars
character will make an appearance there
are apparently 300 playable characters
in the game so chances are they're there
the structure of skywalker saga
represents the greatest deviation from
the lego formula at the beginning of the
game you are given the choice to pick
from the start of each trilogy campaigns
will mix the more traditional lego
levels with open hubs for each planet
you can explore for example you can
explore the hub area of the mos eisley
spaceport and then when you're ready you
can head over to the next objective to
continue the story using a galaxy map
you can travel to each planet unlocking
them as they show up in the plot but are
able to return to previously visited
locations whenever you want these planet
hubs are where a lot of the game's
exploration is you can talk to npcs and
do small side quests for them there's
collectibles to find and puzzles to
solve there's even a brand new rumor
system where you can pay a few studs to
get a hit on where a particular unlock
is such as a ship and speaking of ships
these hubs just are on the planet's
surface you can also fly above in a ship
of your choosing with even more quests
and collectibles to find you can even
get in aerial dogfights with a squadron
of tie fighters combat has also received
a few upgrades melee weapons like
lightsabers have a basic combo system to
give fights more depth than simply
smashing one button
ranged weapons use a third-person
over-the-shoulder perspective letting
players have more accurate shots you can
even take cover in certain spots like in
lego star wars the force awakens
the games many many characters are all
split into different roles for certain
tasks jedis can use the force droids can
use certain doors etc there's also a
skill tree you can use to upgrade these
rolls increasing health blaster damage
and faster build speed to name a few to
get these upgrades you'll need to find
kyber bricks hidden throughout the
galaxy's many planets it has been
confirmed there is no custom character
creator like in lego stars 2 the
original trilogy certainly a bummer from
my point of view as i have very fond
memories of spending time with my best
friend building our own custom star wars
characters in that game and speaking of
playing with friends the series staple
co-op makes a return at any time a buddy
can hop into your game with some good
old-fashioned split screen unfortunately
if you don't have a friend to invite
over to your house you're out of luck as
there is no online multiplayer of any
kind
when it comes to post release wb games
has confirmed seven dlc character packs
for the skywalker saga these tap into
many of the recent star wars non-trilogy
movies as well as the disney plus tv
shows the packs available at launch are
the mandalorian season 1 and solo a star
wars story the classic character pack is
available if you buy the game at certain
retailers and will be available later on
april 19th the rogue one a star wars
story pack will also release on april
19th the trooper pack comes included if
you pre-purchase the digital version
and can be bought separately on may 4th
also available on may 4th is the
mandalorian season 2 and the bad batch
packs keep in mind all of these are
simply new characters and don't include
levels and boy is that a lot to keep
track of if you rather just get
everything in one bundle there is the
character collection the skywalker
saga's version of a season pass which
gives you all seven of these character
packs
[Music]
lego star wars the skywalker saga
launches on april 5th
like with all lego games travelers tales
is bringing the skywalker saga to every
major platform pc nintendo switch
playstation 4 xbox one and the current
generation versions for ps5 and xbox
series x slash s the standard edition
comes at 59.99 us dollars on all
platforms and there's also the deluxe
edition which costs an additional 10
and comes with the character collection
bundle the skywalker saga has been a
long time coming first announced all the
way back in e3 2019 and has had multiple
delays
by the way if you want to know more
about the behind the scenes development
i highly recommend checking out this
excellent polygon article detailing the
game's 5 year development and sadly the
brutal crunch the developers have had to
endure
and that is everything you need to know
about lego star wars the skywalker saga
are you a long time lego fan new to the
series
or are you like me and played the
original lego star wars games way back
in the day and are just now returning
for this new one make sure to click
subscribe to gamespot so you're informed
when our full review of the game comes
out thanks for watching
[Music]
you